[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec jean baptiste
à monique maire de villepreux président
du modem des yvelines bonjour moi genre
on va parler des élections
départementales et régionales qui auront
finalement lieu les 20 et 27 juin
prochain il ya eu un débat un moment sur
le report vous est il plutôt favorable
au report ou au maintien
alors je sais que la position nationale
en tout cas du mouvement démocrate
c'était d'être plutôt en faveur du
report notamment pour des raisons
sanitaires mais pas uniquement
nous on a consulté un consulter les élus
locaux du modem de 78 dans les yvelines
c'est aussi le report qui était plutôt
majoritaire mais avec un petit peu moins
un petit peu moins d' avance que sur le
maintien à titre personnel en tant que
mère moi je vous avoue avoir plutôt
exprimé d'ailleurs lors de la
consultation qui a été lancée par la
préfecture
je me suis plutôt exprimé en faveur du
maintien parce que je ne sais pas ce que
sera le contexte sanitaire notamment à
l'automne et parce que je crois qu'il
faut quand même qu'on puisse avancer sur
le processus démocratique notamment à la
proche de ces deux élections
est ce qu'en tant que maire pour
l'instant c'est peut-être un peu tout
mais vous risquez d'avoir des
difficultés notamment pour trouver des
assesseurs
alors à l'heure où je vous parle il me
reste encore une vingtaine d'assesseurs
à trouver parce que évidemment comme
vous le savez on dédouble les bureaux de
vote avec ce double scrutin même si on
peut mutualiser certaines fonctions
c'est un défi c'est un défi logistique
et organisationnel mais on va y arriver
on a eu l'occasion en plus de faire
vacciner l'ensemble du personnel à la
fois communal les élus
et puis les assesseurs déjà connus qui
seront mobilisés sur les deux tours sur
les 20 et 27 juin prochains grâce
notamment à leur éligibilité a décidé
par l'état donc ils ont pu se faire
vacciner au vélodrome
et c'est vrai que on est en train de
regarder avec attention les différents
protocoles qui nous sont qui nous ont
été communiqués par le ministère de
l'intérieur
on va y arriver j'ai pas de crainte
particulière là dessus mais en tout cas
oui on cherche encore des bonnes voulons
et pour venir apporter un peu plus de
confort aux équipes qui seront mobilisés
sur ces deux dimanches de joie alors
c'est un appel prononcé est ce que vous
craignez quand même que le grand
vainqueur de ces élections
départementales et régionales le premier
parti ce soit le parti de l'abstention
oui mais je vais vous dire je le lis pas
au contexte sanitaire
je crois que les raisons seront
peut-être un peu plus profonde que cela
quand vous regardez historiquement de
toute façon la participation sur ces
scrutins on va pas dire que ce sont des
scrutins qui passionne les foules et
c'est malheureux parce que les
départementales sont le scrutin de
proximité par excellence avec des
élections municipales
et quand on connaît aussi notamment le
rôle et les compétences des régions je
crois que c'est un scrutin qui devrait
mobiliser davantage de concitoyens
surtout à l'heure de la relance les
régions auront évidemment un rôle à
jouer mais c'est vrai que je m'attends
aujourd'hui à une forte abstention
j'espère qu'elle ne sera pas massive en
tout cas on a tous je crois un devoir
une responsabilité qui est d'appeler nos
concitoyens aux urnes quel que soit leur
choix mais il faut que la démocratie
puisse à la fois vivre et s'exprimer
en tout cas que les électeurs puissent
s'exprimer et donc nous localement en
tout cas à villepreux
on essaye sur cette partie citoyenne sur
cette partie civique d'encourager les
gens à les écouter et pour ce qui est du
contexte sanitaire on en parlait
justement aussi en les rassurant sur les
différentes dispositions qui seront
prises
moi je crois très sincèrement que les
bureaux de vote les 20 et 27 juin
prochain seront sans doute les endroits
les plus sécure on va dire sanitairement
parlant de france avec vraiment des
protocoles qui sont très strictes avec
du gel hydroalcoolique à disposition
avec des masques au final toutes ces
choses que nous n'avions pas pour les
élections municipales et puis surtout
avec des gens qui seront vaccinés moi ce
que je vais proposer notamment en
partenariat avec la région c'est que les
électeurs qui le souhaitent puissent se
faire dépister aussi 48 heures avant le
premier tour de la sorte si le résultat
leur revient positif
eh ben ils pourront se mettre à
l'isolément et ne pas risquer d'aller
compte a dit d'aller contaminer d'autres
personnes aussi le jour de l'élection
donc il faut qu'on soit tous
responsables évidemment et qu'on essaye
tant bien que mal de faire en sorte que
ce scrutin puisse se tenir dans les
meilleurs conditions
impossible mais j'y crois en tout cas on
fait tout ce qu'il faut nous je crois
dans nos villes pour pour que ça se
passe bien et pour réduire comme son pré
occupations effectivement le taux
d'abstention qui s'annonce encore une
fois assez conséquent et vous avez
raison de dire oui que les conditions ne
seront pas les mêmes que celles que
qu'on devait rencontrer pour les
municipales alors il ya deux élections
il ya les élections départementales des
élections régionales
commençons par les départementales vous
soutenez la liste de pierre bédier vous
êtes vous même vous êtes le suppléant de
philippe benassaya députés aient l'air
qui fait équipe avec sonia broc maire de
saint cyr l'école dans le canton de
saint cyr l'école alors sur une liste
sur laquelle on retrouve donc des modems
comme vous retrouve florence grange ou
kaki et députés des deux si elle rm qui
est elle aussi suppléante est ce qu'il
vous voit dans ce rassemblement une
ouverture politique c'est à dire qu'il
s'agit de dépasser les frontières de la
droite
ou alors est ce que c'est juste une
réponse aux enjeux de cette élection qui
sont des enjeux départementaux
ce sont des enjeux départementaux je le
disais tout à l'heure le scrutin
départemental et le scrutin avec le
scrutin municipal de proximité par
excellence
je rejoins perdu est perdu pierre bédier
pardon quand il dit que c'est
départementales sont le troisième tour
des élections municipales c'est vrai
c'est avec les équipes municipales en
place qu'on construit des candidatures
pour les départementales notamment pour
aller porter les dossiers et les sujets
qui sont apportées par les différentes
équipes municipales
il n'y a pas de surprise dans le sens où
vous savez nous le modem en 2015 nous
étions partie prenante de la campagne
départementale en partenariat notamment
avec la droite et avec nos amis
centristes de l'udf
moi je suis ravie aujourd'hui de voir
que il ya rassemblement plus large
encore qu'il ait pu se faire dès le
début en tout cas avant le premier tour
vous avez cité effectivement la députée
grand jeu qui n'est membre de la
république en marche
on peut citer julliard chambon le mr de
huy il est effectivement plusieurs
candidats modem
donc on est dans une logique d'accord
global départemental avec des gens qui
ne pensent pas effectivement tous la
même chose au niveau national et
d'ailleurs pour ce qui me concerne je
suis donc en soutien en tant que
suppléant à la candidature du conseiller
départemental philippe benassaya pas
forcément d'ailleurs du député qui a
d'autres idées au niveau national mais
ça se passe très bien parce que on ne
met entre personnes intelligentes et on
est entre personnes qui ont bien compris
que l'intérêt aujourd'hui sur ces
élections départementales c'était de
parler du local de parler de la
préoccupation des gens avec un slogan
qui plus qu'un slogan le département qui
protège c'est effectivement ce qui nous
rassemble est ce qui nous anime
aujourd'hui la défense défendre en tout
cas nos concitoyens sur l'aspect
sanitaire sur l'aspect sécuritaire tout
un tas de thématiques en tout cas sur
l'aspect environnemental aussi donc moi
j'ai pas de il n'y a pas de sujet de
positionnement il n'y a pas de
manoeuvres je crois les torts allemand
plus et puis il faut quand même
souligner un dernier point contrairement
peut-être à l'élection régionale c'est
que vous avez des territoires
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines où le
risque et rennes est très très fort il
l'est beaucoup plus qu'il n'était
notamment aux dernières législatives aux
dernières départemental de 2015 donc
l'union puisse se faire
sur un scrutin local pour parler des
problématiques du quotidien je crois que
c'est très positif
et moi je suis assez satisfait de voir
qu'on ait pu s'entendre
justement sur cette élection justement
parlez du et rennes qui jusqu'ici n'a
pas fait des scores fantastique dans les
yvelines même s'il ya eu la mairie de
mantes la ville vendeurs pendant pendant
un mandat
là on pressent peut-être qu'ils aient
une montée en effet vous sentez ça dans
ce département
vous savez que j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec mon prédécesseur qui était présent
de même 78 députés bruno myle yen qui
est député les deux du nord du
département d'un territoire très rural
on l'a senti on l'a vu et je le vois
encore et je le vois encore au quotidien
sur cette partie très rurale du
département sur le nord du département
sur le nord ouest en l'occurrence on
sent on sent une montée on sent une
montée des extrêmes on sent une montée
du rassemblement national
donc c'est vrai que il ya deux solutions
soit en l'occultent et on se dit que ça
passera comme on a l'habitude de se dire
sur les élections c'est à dire que
finalement sur des élections à deux
tours
l'électeur l'électorat qu'on dit
républicain au sens front républicain
les lecteurs doivent avoir un sursaut et
tout le monde à se rassembler derrière
la candidature qui sera contre l'extrême
contre la candidature de l'extrême
droite moi je crois qu'il faut il faut
maintenant traiter le sujet en
profondeur donc il ya un aspect
évidemment programme
il ya un aspect être vraiment dans le
concret et parler des vraies
préoccupations des gens et il ya un
aspect évidemment rassemblement dès le
premier tour aujourd'hui c'est vrai il
faut le dire que une multiplication de
candidatures sur des cantons où le
risque front national est très élevé
peut être peut être en danger
et moi je ne souhaite pas même si
évidemment aujourd'hui candidat du front
national
il ya des électeurs qui votent pour eux
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une partie de
la population qui se retrouvent dans ces
candidatures mais mon souhait ce n'est
pas de voir des conseillers
départementaux du rassemblement national
au département des yvelines donc c'est
une bataille politique c'est une
bataille idéologique une bataille
programmatique et donc oui il faut la
mener sur tous les territoires
il ya une attention apportée
particulièrement sur le nord du
département
l'an passé face à montréjeau val d'isère
dans l'élection départementale vous êtes
fait équipe avec philippe benassaya
appui aux régionales philippe benassaya
va probablement voter pour valérie
pécresse et vous pour le rang saint
martin le candidat de l hérault modèle
comment on peut expliquer alors cette
différence qu'on est d'acord au
département est pas d'accord pour la
région alors il ya plusieurs
explications à cela je pense que encore
une fois comme je le disais les
départementales c'est un scrutin
vraiment de grande proximité les
régionales même si la région moi je
crois en tant que maire oeuvre
aujourd'hui dans le quotidien de nos
concitoyens mais aussi auprès des
communes dans leurs projets
d'investissement dans dans d'autres dans
d'autres opérations également
c'est peut-être un échange qui paraît
encore un petit peu plus éloignés et
c'est vrai que c'est un échelon qui est
très politisée on a l'habitude de dire
notamment en ile-de-france que le
conseil régional c'est un petit peu
l'antichambre de l'assemblée nationale
ou encore que les élections régionales
sont un peu le galop d'essai d'une
élection présidentielle à venir d'autant
plus cette année avec des élections
régionales qui vont se peut passer un
petit peu moins d'un an avant l'élection
présidentielle
moi j'ai pas de souci de de
positionnement et je crois que
d'ailleurs nos collègues de droite qui
partent avec nous au départemental non
plus parce que pierre bédier l'a dit
lors de la conférence de presse
d'annoncé de la candidature des
candidats huppé y étaient des alliés on
peut avoir un candidat différent pour
les régionales c'est pas le même de
scrutin c'est ça qui est très important
on parlait du risque front national tout
à l'heure moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui pour l'île de france
je dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de risque
rassemblement national mais en tout cas
le risque de mon point de vue par
rapport à ce que je crois
par rapport à mes convictions propres
c'est plutôt une bascule de la région
une nouvelle fois à gauche après la
victoire de valérie pécresse en 2015
ça je crois qu'il faut absolument
l'éviter mais vous êtes sur un scrutin à
deux tours à la proportionnelle un
scrutin de liste ou si vous n'avez pas
réussi à faire l'union au premier tour
potentiellement vous pouvez le faire au
second
d'ailleurs la gauche ne manquera pas de
le faire mais au premier tour il n'y a
pas de souci et je crois pour exprimer
une sensibilité un peu différente
exprimer des idées différentes des idées
qui nous sont propres
voir aussi ce qui a pu être trop bien
fait et le dire parce que des choses
positives ont pu être faits sous cette
mandature et voir aussi là où peut-être
qu'il ya eu quelques trous
la raquette où quelque chose quelques
voilà quelque chose qu'on peut encore un
petit peu améliorée et je crois que la
candidature aujourd'hui vie de nos rangs
saint martin s'inscrit dans cette dans
cette démarche là contrairement aux
départementales il n'y a pas eu de
proposition en tout cas de la majorité
sortante d'élargir dès le premier tour
on peut peut-être le regretter mais en
tout cas c'est une réalité est peut-être
que s'il y avait eu cette main tendue
une candidature peut être commune aurait
pu se faire dès le premier tour en tout
cas aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je crois que il n'ya pas
d'ennemis il n'y a pas d'adversaire mais
il ya la volonté de porter un projet
pour les franciliens et d'ailleurs c'est
aujourd'hui que jean noël barrot et
aurore bergé qui sont les deux têtes de
listes départementales pour les yvelines
de sa petite liste régionale présentée
mais candidat et je suis plutôt heureux
de voir que le figurent sur cette liste
des personnes de grande qualité et
représentative de l'ensemble de nos
territoires du département
merci beaucoup jean baptiste abu dis que
vous avez très bien expliquer justement
ben voilà c'est différent centralisée
par total et les régionales merci merci
à vous merci pour votre invitation
[Musique]